今じゃはじめ冊はですゲージに来て早1週間が経ったんですけど髪の毛も
なんかだいぶ切ったんですけど伸びてきてただもうちょっと伸びたらきっとまだまだ
マシになると思うんで
んでまぁ
何が言いたいかというと
ちょっと
今日はですねもうそろそろ何か行き店の
ここが綺麗に言うとかなんかすごいでしょイギリスみたいなそういうなんか
イギリス自慢動画はもうやめておきます
たぶん見てても飽きてくると思うんで
イギリスの素敵なところアーチが素敵なところはこっちだしますよ
素敵なところとかはことに出すんですけど何かイギリスの日常とか
こんなことがあったよとかそういうのはサブチャンネルに出すんでまたイイみて
ください今日はね
1回僕が学校から帰るときバスを間違えて
迷っていったところが凄いきれいだったんで
そこに行こうっていう話じゃいくよ
ん
ということでここが
僕が家に帰る時に迷って見つけたなんか綺麗なところです車 v 試合切りしてああ
公園とかあってなんか
ちょっと小奇麗な感じなんで
凄いきれいな家と見ていきましょう
朝がイギリスでもねー
いきミスで外にできるって僕も勇者ですからね
ここここらを通すかん
この入りスティングな感じたがないした
べきお天気も良くて何か良い滑る事で
voodoo
これでこれこれすげーこれすごい
ちょっと待ったら
た戻っん
僕をれたですねランク4
ん
これはデカイん
4日
以上オックスフォードの公園からでした
じゃあ
car